all right hi there how are you I'm very
good at Tiger then fine thank you
it's great to talk to you after such a
long time I think yeah let me say my
what Benny the Irish polyglot famous
Globetrotter linguist as I call it
polyglot and general cheerleader for
language learning around the world who
has touched many many people with his
enthusiasm that's right so it's a
pleasure to talk to you and what I want
to talk to you about today is the
upcoming polyglot conference in Montreal
I have never been to one of these I
called it the language festival festival
day long I have no idea what to expect
maybe you could talk about your
experience and what people who haven't
yet signed first of all those who have
signed up what they can expect there and
why other people should hurry up and
register yeah definitely
so so far I have been at the polytope
caverns which are usually in Berlin and
polyglot conference which has moved
locations several times and each time it
has been a fantastic experience so the
first thing I should say it is not a
polyglot exclusive club so if somebody
does not speak foreign languages five
languages or more then they don't have
to think okay I'm not good enough to
attend because there's a lot of people
who are aspiring like and they go to
meet people if they know on YouTube and
to get to know them in person and so at
these events you have people giving
presentations and these are people that
you might recognize from YouTube from
podcasts from blogs so familiar faces
talking about a topic that they're
passionate about and then between those
talks you have other things like you
might have a picnic or you might have a
game show that you can take part in or
you might be able to join people to
watch a foreign language movie but best
of all you just get to talk to people
and get to know them better so for me
these
events have been an opportunity to get
to know the language like language
learning community face to face I mean
it is extraordinary this language
learning community like I have never met
you I've never actually shaken your hand
so to speak me but we're very much aware
of each other as we are of other people
on the internet who talk about language
learning but I sometimes get concerned
that we are this little get hold on
people and they're not not just a
handful there might be but even if it's
a hundred what's a hundred you know
language
Keener's compared to the literally
hundreds of millions of people who at
some level want to learn another
language and yet for a variety of
reasons
hang back feel uncertain lack confidence
and stuff like that so for these people
what can they get like the non as you
say the non polyglot or maybe someone
who's been you know forever trying to
learn Spanish what do they get what do
they come away with from one of these
conferences so the first thing they come
away with is the actual talks that take
place because the talks themselves are
about the process of learning languages
or sometimes specific languages like
someone might have a passion for Welsh
or Scottish or something and they might
finally talk about that right so it's
it's a project it's a learning it's like
that opportunity to learn about those
things but also they will meet others
like them so it's not just about meeting
polyglots they may follow online like
yourself and many other polyglots it's
also a chance to meet other people who
are in the same situation as them and I
think there is like your sectors
let's say there's maybe 100 people that
have a sizable amount of followers who
are making videos in multiple languages
and there's also many thousands of
people who just might have that interest
but they're not really gonna be
uploading YouTube videos right but
rather than them
to aspire to those other people they can
get a lot of inspiration from others
like themselves who have that special
interest and I know you've had your own
meetups whenever you go in and travel to
cities
yeah and it's great for those people to
get to meet you but I'm sure you see
that you have this catalyst where they
get to talk to each other and they get
to exchange ideas and it's like that on
a very large scale right right and to be
honest the meetups that I have they
again tend to attract language Keener's
not necessarily people who put up videos
of themselves but people who speak three
four or five languages I think part of
our mission we feel is to get the you
know monolingual unilingual person to
make the jump because it is such a
wonderful thing to be able to speak
other languages to connect with other
people and I think they're I agree with
you that you know there's something
about this world where we're connected
you know it's that warmth of other
people trying to do the same thing as
you and it just generates that level of
enthusiasm and energy that a person
needs to take on a language because it's
a long haul like it's not like it's a
long haul and so so you you you meet
people that maybe will become friends of
yours going forward and they will keep
you motivated and energized and be an
inspiration so plus you might pick up
some tips yeah did that work for you
everybody yep yeah talk about they do
get the chance to meet people who they
do like to follow online face to face so
at the events that I've been out already
one thing I found very interesting is
you know we we have our like
presentation of ourselves that we have
online right I have my videos that I
make that put a lot of effort into and I
try to make them exciting and fun and so
on and there's that kind of Benny the
Irish party type persona right but I'm
also just a normal guy man
you know we're all we're all human
beings we all just like to hang out with
people and talk about whatever right and
I felt that a lot of those events have
been a chance for me to make real
friends with people once they City and
I'm just like they are and I I just want
to hang out I just want to talk about
stuff you know and I think that also
helps them to see rather than thinking
oh my god they're so talented and so
smart that I like bring being brought
down to their level right you know and
being understood that we're all the same
how much hard work will do for you you
know and it's easy enough to say well
he's talented I could do that but in
fact you can then he okay just change
the tack a little bit you've been very
successful I've followed your career
you've been successful because of your
enthusiasm your energy your imagination
and so you have you know you had your
website or your blog and then you had
your book I don't know if you're willing
to talk about some of the other things
that you have planned
if so absolut knows I think a lot of
people would be interested here yeah so
um in all of my troubles I have there's
two tools that I say I would come back
to use a lot which would be the teacher
sub courses and also I talk EW I talk
about I talk a lot as I those for me to
find teachers so an amazing opportunity
came up and it has been one reason
you'll see very few videos that I've
uploaded over the last year or so is
because I have been extraordinarily busy
making new language courses with teacher
self so it's the same publisher who owns
the rights to Michelle Thomas it's the
same publisher who published Charles
Darwin's theory of evolution so this is
a very established name for sure in
teaching people and what I thought was I
I've never made a course before because
I like encouraging people and I didn't
feel I would know anything about making
courses because that requires an
understanding of the academic stuff
involved and how questions and answers
and all that stuff works that others
would have decades of experience in that
I don't have so for me when they invited
me to do this it meant it was a chance
to collaborate so I could take all of
that know how that teacher self has in
making excellent courses and then
sprinkle a little bit of my
encouragement on us I'm just kind of
give it that extra little burst of
personality and the kind of stuff I
focus on because I generally like
helping people
as you said monolinguals so it's for
absolute beginners and those are going
to be coming out in September and we're
no images of Hermes so yeah they were
starting with four we're starting with
Spanish French German and Italian so the
four big languages and I have a strategy
with this essentially from already doing
a book and seeing how the marketing
works and the interest works and how
bookstores work I wanted to start with
these big languages to show to
bookstores that they can that they're
profitable that they can sell these
books and people will buy them and then
after that when the series is
established I'm going to be able to
start titles for languages that have
been neglected in language learning
courses so I may be able to make an
Irish language learning course that can
go around the world
I can work with translators to make
these courses work well for immigrant
communities so we can translate the
German course to Kurdish and make it
dialect friendly for Arabic for the
Syrian immigrants in in Germany for
instance and these are all the things
that I'm really looking forward to doing
once we've established the course with
the bigger language right so I'm really
excited as being yes we could be very
very busy because you can imagine it's
that writing for books in a year it's
not something you do part-time now when
you say you're collaborating so you're
working
with the people who normally design the
teacher sell books and that's right
working with them to modify it to bring
it more in line with the way you think
people should learn or or no well no not
necessarily modified essentially I've
created the course from scratch made my
own course but I worked with them right
the entire time to make sure so like I
might not know how I don't know how to
make a table to present the information
to people right and then they would come
in and help me kind of tweak it the
right direction
and then the whole presentation and the
layout and the unit structure that you
have different units teaching a
different topic so they kind of guided
it I mean I got to have a lot of my own
voice and inspiration into the pages so
I really feel like it's it's not just me
editing and already present teacher sup
book it's a brand new course alright and
now you also mentioned I talkies there's
some element of I talking in there yes
so we have a partnership with I talkie
where essentially what makes this course
unique is I was think of it as a
precursor to the other teachers of
course is the like teacher self complete
it's a good course to get yourself to an
intermediate level and like I said we do
different things to try to inspire a new
language learners and my focus happens
to be to get people to speak if that's
what they're interested in you know and
I would always and just so you know I
genuinely and this is honestly if
someone says Benny I'm not really that
interested in speaking I wouldn't learn
a reader language I always say okay you
should check out this guy Steve Kaufman
he's got loads of great advice for you
cuz when people have that interest
that's what they need to focus on but if
people have a spoken interest then I
designed this to be around - so at the
end of each unit we get them to go
online and actually use their language
so this isn't a theoretical thing but at
the end of the course maybe they can use
a little bit during the course itself
they go
they use it and they come back and
continue and go and use it and we do
that in conjunction with teachers with
that I target I think that's a very good
plan it's an example of how the internet
opens up so many more opportunities
because I mean to be perfectly honest I
have used teach yourself to get started
on a number of languages I have used I
talk he when he didn't have you know
tutors at Lane for like for example for
Polish and so yeah and the idea that the
person has bought this teach yourself
and is chapter 5 and and now they
actually have to go and use it so they
can connect with someone to use it I
think that's a very good use of of the
internet and certainly those low most
resources I found I found very very good
so I'm sure it'll be it'll be successful
I will look forward to just to let just
to update you briefly at link where just
by the way we also encourage people to
speak although and we'll get it yeah
Montreal but yeah better than any rate
it's it we don't necessarily rightly or
wrongly necessarily person to speak
right away although the opportunity is
there we are working on a beta version
right now which I am using which at
least for me it seems a significant
improvement over what we now have in
particular the mobile app so at some
point if you're gonna take on a new
language you might want to give it a try
but we can talk about all of that when
I'm in Montreal but I think what you've
outlined there tying your because very
often language learning is a lonely
activity very often and so someone who's
bought the teach yourself book is at
home trying to learn this lesson and
it's very easy for the enthusiasm to
flag
so yeah I have you know Benny not
necessarily cracking the whip but
inspiring you and at the same time
encouraging you to connect through I
talky to a native speaker I think that's
an excellent plan and I think I think
you'll be very successful yeah and I
look forward to seeing that thank you
very much yeah okay well look I think
we've we've briefly covered what what
you've been up to so far as I'm
concerned the fact that a beta will be
available hopefully before Montreal but
we'll see
and but
I think we want people I guess most of
all big picture we want people to learn
languages you know recently with the
brexit and so people are saying is this
gonna affect the role of English in the
world and it to me and then other people
say well English is you know we should
all speak Esperanto because English is
you know anglo-saxon imperialism you
know none of that really matters I think
it is becoming easier easier to learn
languages an example is our discussion
the way you're working with teach
yourself they found out about you
through the internet you connect
together for them i talky with what
they're doing with what benny has been
doing and you know his blog post so this
is the new world so people can learn
languages a lot more easily than 50
years ago which is before your time when
I was learning many Chinese so the
message is it's easier than ever to
learn languages and all you really need
is the inspiration and the motivation
and that you can get big time by coming
to the Montreal and I call it the
language festival because someone in the
office was saying most English speakers
don't know the meaning of the word
symposium and they don't know the
meaning of the word polyglot so we have
the North American blue polyglot
symposium it's a language festival
festival day long for our French class
and yeah maybe give a final rousting
challenge to people to come up and
broaden their horizons yeah yeah
definitely and if anyone wants to find
out more about it they should go to na
Polycom and they'll see a list of the
talks that you and I and everyone else
is going to be giving and they'll get a
taste of what's going to go on that
weekend and they can of course sign up
and it would be great to see them in
they see me they should come say hi and
they say either she come say I
absolutely and if they find us at a bar
with about four or five empty beer
is there they should leave us alone I
might be on the the orange juice myself
in the bar but I don't get you I
actually don't drink this is I'm
challenged your IRA stereotypes are you
are yeah people have always said oh
that's they denied you your Irish
passport because of that and you know
I'm like har har har okay Oh
stereotypes aside looking forward to
seeing you and thank you for the
discussion all right thanks for having
me Steve I will see you next time thank
you bye bye